a couple days ago actually not a couple
days ago like a couple weeks ago
i got an email from a lovely young woman
named marisol
and marisol says this hello rob
i hope you and your loved ones are doing
great i'm writing to you with great
excitement
and honor my boyfriend and i watch all
your new videos
a few months ago i joked with my
boyfriend about how nice it would be
for you to know how much of a fan he is
thank you
he's always he's always super excited
with your new content
i can't talk it's a whole vibe well
andrew's birthday is coming up on april
24th and if it's not too much to ask
can you give him a birthday shout out
please and then she gave me his full
name i'm not going to repeat his full
name here
thank you for your videos we're looking
forward for many more well thank you
andrew for being a fan i really
appreciate that
and so i feel like this being the first
time i've ever actually made a dedicated
video wishing somebody happy birthday
that i should sing happy birthday to you
so
everybody watching this video sing with
me here
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear andrew
happy birthday to you you know the
hardest part
about it being your birthday the
weirdest part about being your birthday
people sing happy birthday to you and
you just sit there and look awkward
right listen i never know what to do
when somebody's wishing me happy
birthday it's like
i just have to sit here and be awkward
while people are wishing me happy
birthday like
singing happy birthday they saw me
anyway happy birthday andrew and as a
birthday gift
as a birthday gift i'm going to give you
a rob core ring so mayor saul or andrew
whichever one of you guys uh perfectly
marisol because i already have your
email
send me a follow-up email attached to
this existing one so i know it's
actually you
and let me know what andrew's ring size
is and and give me your information and
everything
and i will i will mail a rob core ring
to you and because it's a very special
occasion i will mail you a rob core
honor guard ring which is a ring you can
only get if you're on patreon
so uh yeah happy birthday andrew and i
will catch you all later
peace